تونس السياحه تتعافى بالفعل في تونس فلاول
مره منذ ازمه كورونا والاسماء الخانقه
التي تعرض لها قطاع السياحه زياده بمعدل
13% تقريبا في الثلاثي عفوا في الرباعي
الاول للسنه الحاليه مقارنه بارقام 2019
التي تعتبر الارقام المرجعيه بالنسبه الى
وزاره السياحه والى السلطات السوياحيه
يتوافدون على تونس القطاع يتعافى وخاصه
اسواق المدينه العتيقه في تونس وسوسه
وجربه وغيرها من زوايا تونس الجميله تعود
اليها البهجه من جديد طيب موضوع ثاني ايضا
لديك
احلام فرحه كبيره لام وبنتها بتخرجوا بنفس
اليوم شو القصه
من قال ان الاحلام تتوقف الاحلام لا تتوقف
ان كانت هناك عزيمه بلال خريفيش طالب
تونسي يتحصل على شهادته الجامعيه في
التجاره في نفس الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
وان تتخرج لحسن الحظ في نفس الاسبوع مع
ابنها وقد سبق وانت حصلت على شهاده
البكالوريا هي وابنها في نفس العام في عام
2020 احلام سنوقف الاحلام عن الحديث ولكنك
دائما موجوده في قلوبنا احلام العبدلي
شكرا جزيلا لك يعيشك يعيشك انت لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات